it's Thursday July thirtieth and you're
watching gamespot news I'm Chris waters
here to deliver the news in a calm and
collected way apparently some of my
previous attempts you better listen up
real good to attract your attention
don't you tab away from me have been
deemed too aggressive get that news in
your face all by certain test audiences
yeah that's fine I welcome the
constructive criticism here's today's
news I hope you choke on it enjoy it
console sales numbers have come in for
q1 2015 and wouldn't you know it
PlayStation 4's have outsold Xbox one's
almost two to one okay that's not
entirely true because while Sony
reported the number of ps4 sold
Microsoft only reported the number of
Microsoft consoles sold so three million
ps4s to 1.4 million xbox one and xbox
360's combined sony reported a
year-on-year revenue increase of
thirty-eight percent while Microsoft was
down five percent for more on the
financial reports from both companies
check out the full story on gamespot com
/ news all those millions of new
playstation 4 owners may soon get to
vote on which games they get for free on
playstation plus a service that they
have to pay for a NeoGAF forum user in
the UK spotted a video describing a new
feature called vote to play it appears
that players will be given a choice of
three games and a limited period of time
in which to vote the winner will be
added to the list of free PS Plus games
for the month while the losers will be
offered at a discount again for PS plus
members the games displayed in the video
are our mellow grow home and zombie
Vikings so start researching now so you
can make a thoughtful and inform
decision there's no joke here that's
just how you should vote on all things
all the time do you folks remember that
wii u launch games zombie you with the
puzzles and the cricket bat and the
zombies and the zombies well an upgraded
port of that survival horror game is
coming to a console near you
specifically the xbox one and the
PlayStation 4 and also the PC ubisoft is
planning to sell the new version
digitally starting August eighteenth
and they will be dropping the you to
make the title simply zombie because
zombies don't need higher education and
also because the you is more of a wii u
thing i guess i mean what would they
even study intro to human flight
patterns deconstructing human survival
tactics modern shamble advanced radha
nomics star wars battlefront is coming
out november seventeenth and EA CFO
Peter Moore says that a delay is not
going to happen when asked by MCV if
they would ever dare to delay the game
amidst the massive marketing push that
will no doubt be coming later this year
Moore said we would have no compunction
no hesitation whatsoever that if
something was to go wrong with star wars
battlefront if it wasn't right we would
just push it and if you believe that
I've got some pristine waterfront
territory to sell you somewhere in the
Dagobah system and finally there's some
rocket League DLC on the way in August
there are some new cars and new cosmetic
bits like these six spinners as well as
a spectator mode that will allow for
thrilling East sports broadcasts that
will vault this fantastic game into its
rightful place in the competitive
pantheon you had a good run baseball but
it's time to step aside because you're
boring and terrible speaking of which
all this news jibber-jabber has been
taking precious time away from my rocket
League practice so you're welcome be
sure to check out gamespot com for all
the latest news come back tomorrow for
top 5 news stories of the week happy
rocket leaking
you